I a circus is funny I when I met Perez
he came to do an mtv PS it turns out he
was a member of my fan club since he was
eight years old he went to one of the
first shows that we had in Miami where
we had first broken big with dr. bead
and we did the Dade County auditorium
which to us was a huge venue at the time
and he was there he was he's a
card-carrying member of my fan club
which I am thankful for very much but
he's a homeboy to you know he's cuban
guy he talked about opportunities on the
net he has created an amazing career
very successful career on his own with
his computer sitting at a cafe so that
shows you the power of the net and I'm
very fortunate that he's a big fan and
he's he you know he's very loyal I'm
very thankful for that